pas bien croyez vous qu'il y ait de pata
plus je ne vous trompez pas notez bien
sur vos droits
ils ont des plus jolies y en a pas à
lopata que pu être est ensemble ça fait
une heure contador
[Musique]
alors pas ta que c'est pour aujourd'hui
ou pour demain
je n'ai plus de temps que le vernis le
plus long naturellement je te préviens
je vais donner le départ
pathak heures dernière avertissement tu
n'es plus que les mains rougies une joue
un angle une lèvre pas étonnant que ça
n'avance pas je te préviens on part dans
deux minutes on s'en va mais oui oui oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
o les grossiers personnes mais aussi la
voie la plus belle de la famille
je vais les rejoindre oui mais comment
je pourrais prendre une bicyclette mais
non nous n'en avons pas il ya bien le
chariot de penthaz zut il faudrait que
quelqu'un pussy je suis tout seul
les ailes de patates loup c'est trop
dangereux mais des trucs de pâques un
truc j'ai connu le truc comme dirait se
vit la pâte à clous les potes de vitesse
de patates
[Musique]
je ne sais pas les faire marcher enfin
je vais bien trouvé même s'ils donnent
un mal fou pour être plus belle que
d'habitude vous en faites la brouille
chez vous pathak heures vous êtes tombé
le pata pelouses sont partis sans moi je
les pâtes à boeufs et j'essaie de faire
marcher les boîtes de vitesses de pata
zut pour les rejoindre
nous allons arranger ça mais tout
d'abord sortons pour faire moins de
bruit
vous voyez j'ai fait ça et ça ça n'a
rien donné
[Musique]
qui
ces balles et bat je vais essayer je
suis par qu'elle soit trop petit pour
vous dit pas tout de suite que j'ai des
grands pieds je n'ai pas dit ça bon
[Musique]
elles sont trop petites pour moi c'est
vrai je vais essayer avec les mains
parce qu'il faut ça marche
[Musique]
oh
pas vouloir rendre service
à combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait de
paca plus je ne vous trompez pas compter
bien sûr photo
attention il en manque
[Musique]